[Música]
hola bienvenido a la revista digital
donde abordamos los temas más
importantes del ciberespacio y las redes
sociales y los medios de comunicación de
américa latina y el mundo las nuevas
políticas de privacidad de whatsapp
tienen a muchos usuarios confundidos
sobre si permanecer o no en la
aplicación sin embargo millones de
personas ya decidieron irse a otras
redes de mensajería por temor a que
facebook que es propiedad de whatsapp
tenga acceso a información confidencial
como sus chats en qué consiste en estos
cambios como nos afectan qué
alternativas tenemos y cuáles son sus
pros y contras empezamos a principios de
enero whatsapp advirtió a sus usuarios
que para poder seguir usando la
aplicación debían aceptar las nuevas
condiciones y políticas sobre privacidad
de lo contrario tenían la opción de
eliminar sus cuentas los nuevos términos
que inicialmente no decían mucho hacen
referencia al trato de datos como las
empresas pueden usar servicios alojados
de facebook para almacenar y administrar
sus chats de whatsapp y la asociación
con facebook la noticia alarmó a quienes
usan la app y provocó que millones de
personas descargaron otras aplicaciones
temiendo que sus datos y sus
conversaciones se vieran expuestas
en 2018 estalló el escándalo sobre la
mayor filtración de datos de facebook
que afectó a unos 50 millones de
personas
la reacción de los usuarios de facebook
hicieron que whatsapp pospusiera estos
cambios del 8 de febrero hasta el 15 de
mayo y además se vio obligada a explicar
en qué consistían la compañía claro que
ninguna empresa de facebook podrá
acceder a las conversaciones ya que
éstas se encuentran cifradas es decir
que nadie más que el emisor y el
receptor pueden acceder a ellas sin
embargo lo que sí es seguro es que si
usted decide continuar con whatsapp está
aceptando compartir sus datos con
facebook esto incluye entre otras cosas
su número de teléfono la marca de su
dispositivo móvil y su dirección ip
estas políticas no aplican para los
países de la unión europea y reino unido
debido a las regulaciones que existen en
estos territorios
sabiendo esto deberíamos preocuparnos
consultamos a expertos
la realidad es que estar en internet
implica resignar algún aspecto de la
privacidad pero este revuelo que se armó
con whatsapp generó una especie de
conciencia para empezar a tener más
cuidado en este sentido una de las
recomendaciones que damos es justamente
que cada vez que nos bajamos una
aplicación leer leer puntualmente cuál
es la política de manejo de esa
información cuál es la política de
privacidad como para saber si estamos de
acuerdo o no y en ese sentido seguir
avanzando no utilizar la herramienta
facebook ya recopilaba información de
whatsapp en 2016 la empresa lo dispuso
como una opción para sus usuarios la
diferencia es que ahora será obligatorio
pero para que facebook quiere estos
datos de whatsapp estas medidas tienen
una intención comercial o todo lo que
hacemos en internet deja una huella por
ejemplo el lugar desde donde nos
conectamos y por cuánto tiempo estuvimos
en línea facebook quiere conocer los
comportamientos de las personas en
whatsapp para crear un perfil más
completo de cada consumidor y de esa
forma enviar a sus cuentas de facebook
publicidad basada en sus gustos recuerde
la pauta es la forma en la que estas
empresas obtienen la mayoría de sus
ganancias
si usted no desea compartir más
información de la cuenta existen otras
alternativas aunque hay un sinnúmero de
aplicaciones similares los usuarios se
decidieron por aquellas que gozan de
mensajería encriptada telegram de origen
británico emiratí y signado creada por
una organización sin ánimo de lucro
telegram reportó que en sólo tres días
posteriores al anuncio de whatsapp
recibió 25 millones de usuarios nuevos
en comparación con los 1.5 millones que
se unían a diario el año pasado y que ya
sobrepasó los 500 millones de usuarios
activos pero el historial de esta app no
es menos controversial mientras whatsapp
sólo permite grupos de hasta 256
personas en telegram pueden ser hasta
200.000 y además cuenta con canales para
difundir mensajes a gran escala dos
funcionalidades utilizadas por grupos
terroristas y organizaciones de extrema
derecha para difundir mensajes de odio y
propaganda la plataforma es señalada de
no ejercer ningún tipo de control sobre
estos contenidos
sin embargo existen distintas opciones
cuando se trata de rehusarse a entregar
más información mientras whatsapp
recopila esta información que ven en
pantalla telegram se limita a la
información de contacto personal oa los
contactos y a los identificadores
mientras que signal solo a la
información de contacto whatsapp y
signal tienen cifrado de mensajes de
extremo a extremo mientras que en
telegram sólo funciona cuando se activa
el chat secreto pero este cifrado no
garantiza que se tome una captura de
pantalla de la conversación ya sea desde
el dispositivo receptor o emisor o
whatsapp no permite bloquear esta
funcionalidad para telegram solo es
posible en los chats privados pero sí se
puede hacer desde signal
los medios de comunicación de américa
latina' analizaron por que desinstalar
whatsapp e instalar otras aplicaciones
no es una solución definitiva el diario
el espectador de colombia resalta que la
base de usuarios del servicio de
whatsapp es tan grande que las personas
esencialmente tienen que permanecer en
la plataforma si quieren seguir
comunicándose con contactos específicos
y añade que es probable que el resultado
sea que las personas tendrán más de una
aplicación de mensajería instalada en su
celular el comercio de perú consultó la
opinión de un experto que insta a tener
en cuenta que el hecho de dejar de
utilizar whatsapp pero seguir usando
instagram o facebook implica que como
usuarios seguimos compartiendo una gran
cantidad de datos el universal de méxico
consultó a otro experto que concluyó que
quienes busquen privacidad verdadera no
deben usar internet porque los usuarios
siempre estarán expuestos de manera
individual empresarial y gubernamental
hasta aquí y revista digital recuerde
que si quiere repetir esta u otra misión
de nuestro programa lo puede hacer a
través de nuestra página web www puntos
france24 puntocom
[Música]